[Applause]
i had a minor work issue
come on hey sweetie
guy at work said he'd pay 500 to this
[Music]
if you keep pushing her she's just gonna
dig in harder you gotta have a right
touch christ wade my grandmother could
say that was a failure to advance she
has
bought lasik surgery
rhonda i beg you for your own good do
not shush this woman
oh she should shush herself that blouse
is louder than i could ever be
but seriously huh don't sweat this
maya's stuff yeah
look at jimmy good grades champion
powwow dancer lacrosse king
he's like captain minnesota out there
meanwhile
maya gives away her beadwork for free
she's my daughter and i would take a
bullet for her but
honestly babe i think she may be a dud
she had the nerve to call me weird
i'm the least weird dad rick leclerc
he roller skates to work
i just think if we give her enough space
that's working
so help me wait i am in heels but i will
run across this field and choke you
yeah i'm just happy the kids have time
for their culture and
the community isn't that the whole goal
yeah but how's she gonna make her way in
the world
you know when i was maya's age my folks
always told me you'll never be buffy
saint marie
and i wasn't but i was miss indian world
how does that relate it doesn't i just
wanted to remind you you married up
[Music]
i'm cool right cooler than billy jack
that's how you do it
we're headed to the grocery get some of
that fancy bologna you like
it's more tedella and thank you
and uh your friend benny's lacrosse
stick's looking ragged buy a new one
but tell them it's an extra you had from
them thanks dad
i can keep the change though right i
know
and maya you come with me
[Music]
i have a proposition i pay you
to make 20 pieces of beadwork five
are yours to do with what you will i
would give them away
and the rest i sell for you unless
you want to learn from your old man
maybe start a company together
i have some logo ideas no
okay i sell them two-thirds of the
profits go to your college fund and the
rest
is yours to spend deal
counteroffer how about i have no
interest in starting a business i make
20 pieces
and i keep 20 pieces
fine then no more allowance fine
and no more going to the elders lodge to
be with grandma are you serious
no of course not that would be mean
she's a very old woman
why are you so obsessed with money is
everything like
a deal to you oh good the truck
started because i put gas in it
which costs money because literally
everything
costs money then why am i even in school
i should just quit
and get a job at a sweatshop maya please
you can never keep up with those kids
[Music]